surely notice since the pandemic began a
lot of people on TV have come to you not
from sleek studios but in from inside
their own homes and has turned us all
into amateur set designers and turns out
these efforts are being observed and
even judged
Errol Barnett has that story that's an
automatic three-point deduction called
tailor is not a sports commentator well
it's complicated he's more of an
interior design judge for correspondents
like myself broadcasting from home or as
his Twitter account puts it a room right
up camera angles what a lot of us were
having conversations about it we just
started tweeting about it born out of
his isolation boredom the room rate of
Twitter account is only around one month
old with more than 140,000 followers
sparking attention from those who have
been judged let's start with the rating
you gave me seven out of ten because
what I would like to see a little bit
more personality in the right side of
the screen you've got a decent room
there and I think you could easily get
to an eight I'm sorry mr. O'Keefe
there's just not enough there it's stark
it almost feels like a hostage video
that someone's added a bookcase to I was
being generous Taylor's girlfriend
Jessie helps rate rooms and his daughter
Haley sometimes offers commentary he
says they try to be fair but honest with
their ratings I'm John Dickerson you
said had a perfect wall approach so I
don't refer to this as a bookcase
this is a book wall that covers the
entire wall it's an effective treatment
of it what's a particular interest
figure that he's labeled his libraries
by subject area these are not props
even though all the judges are news
obsessed no home interview background is
safe from being skewered the account has
given schools to a plethora of people
including Gwyneth Paltrow Arnold
Schwarzenegger and beta will Rourke
he's been banished to the basement
apparently it was kind of alarming that
was a frightful room now this former
White House staffer is still involved in
politics chairing a left-leaning PAC
shown front and center on his page but
the money he's raising these days he
says is apolitical we've switched over
to raising money and providing PPE to
hospitals in about I think we're up to
14 States or 15 states we're sending out
boxes of surgical gloves masks of
plastic face shields everyone's under a
lot of pressure a lot of stress it's a
very difficult time for everyone which
is why he hopes he's at least making
people chuckle it's really just intended
to be at breath of fresh air just some
light-hearted content for this moment
that we find ourselves in what kind of
rating would you give yourself not very
good I mean this is like a six tops I'm
willing to be so critical this is sort
of a do as I say not as I do moment I
can see that now if you are interested
in up in your background game Clawd
suggests adding some color something
personal or something from your travels
like I've tried to do with this box from
Hong Kong over here I don't keep added
artwork I was able to get his score up
to a seven out of ten I'm happy to
report and Claude is happy to share that
he's been able to raise enough funds to
send five pallets of PPE to various
hospitals and Native American groups
around the country so the snark isn't
all for nothing the CBS is morning
Saturday
Errol Barnett New York I love that
that's so awesome
Dana I got an eight out of ten kudos to
will and Joe my set producers here and
Katherine Grasso but she took this
picture out of my shot it's the family
portrait my daughter what's up with that
find room for it somewhere